stehen wir jetzt vor einem ersten großen
meeres anstieg ein gigantischer eisberg
ist in der antarktis abgeworben wird
bereits der dritte teil des lassen
schelfeises dem jetzt die auflösung
droht
und das könnte dramatische folgen haben
krieg zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wenn sich als berge vom schelfeis lösen
oder korrekt ausgedrückt das schelfeis
eisberge kalt passiert erstmal gar
nichts das helfe als film sowieso im
meer und verdrängt als schelfeis eisberg
oder auch dann zu wasser geschmolzen
exakt die gleiche menge wasser
der meeresspiegel steigt nicht an das
kappen von eisbergen ist sogar ein
absolut natürlicher vorgang und passiert
immer wieder
doch das was da in der arktis passiert
hat eine andere qualität der blasen
schelfeis ist eigentlich ein chef mit
einer ausdehnung über zehn breitengrade
und einer fläche von mehr als 100.000
quadratkilometer also rund dreimal so
groß wie nordrhein-westfalen eigentlich
denn die zeiten sind vorbei dass larven
helfer als bestand aus vier teilen
lassen a b c und b doch a und b gibt es
nicht mehr
dank des klimawandels vermuten
klimaforscher wasna müssen sich 1995 auf
und laufen
nachdem abbrechen einer 3250
quadratkilometer großen eisplatte 2002
bis sein war das laufen b chef als
10.000 jahre stabil und die folgen der
auflösung von larven b waren dramatisch
die dahinter liegenden gletscher konnten
jetzt deutlich schneller und vor allem
direkt ins meer abfließen mit achtfacher
geschwindigkeit und genau das ist das
problem schelfeis ist der ausläufer von
gletschern dient mehr fließen bei den
niedrigen temperaturen bleibt das
gletschereis auf dem meer weiter als und
bildet auch das schelfeis das den
schnellen abfluss der gletscher im meer
verhindert wie eine barriere experten
experten befürchten jetzt bei lassen
sich genau das gleiche wie bei seinen
geschwistern
doch die konsequenzen wären viel
dramatischer als bei den deutlich
kleineren geschwistern der jetzt
abgebrochene eisberg ist rund eine
billion tonnen schwer und jedes mal
sogar fünf 1800 quadratkilometer groß
mehr als 55 mal so groß wie paris
wahnsinn oder doppelt so groß ist ein
ganzes land wie luxemburg in jedem fall
also rief ich er ist 175 kilometer lang
und rund 100 meter dick diese
wahnsinnigen ausmaße können jetzt
ernsthafte konsequenzen haben laufen b
müsste sich nach dem kalben 2002
innerhalb von wenigen monaten auf der
verlust des eisbergs ließ das ganze
schelfeises instabil werden es würden
sich immer mehr risse und larven b
müssen sie schließlich auf genau das
könnte jetzt auch passieren
wer jetzt entstanden eisberg 68
hinterlässt eine riesige lücke die die
stabilität des ganzen feldes gefährden
könnte
so weit war die grenze des schelfeises
noch nie zurückgekommen
die konsequenzen wären dramatisch denn
die hinter den chef als liegen im
gletscher haben ein viel größeres
potenzial als die gletscher von larven b
haben wie einen ungehinderten fluss zu
märz könnten sie den meeresspiegel
weltweit um zehn zentimeter steigen
lassen
der klimawandel würde sich weiter
beschleunigen und wer könnte sich wieder
beschleunigen auf das abtauen der
antarktis auswirken
insgesamt wird sie von eis bedeckt das
dem meeresspiegel so wird geschätzt um
60 meter steigen lassen kann was jetzt
passiert darüber halten euch natürlich
auf dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video
verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
geo engineering gegen klimawandel wird
co2 tatsächlich aus der atmosphäre
gefiltert und recycelt wenn es euch
interessiert unbedingt draufklicken
ansonsten bis dann platzt